well I'd like the oldest mass games when
they came out like I like smash 64 and I
like me a lot so I was like I just
played the game a lot for a few years
and then I found out that there's
tournaments so I was like hmm he tried
to be the best at that and then two
years later as the best over the course
of his 12-year career
Jayson mew2king Zimmerman has been known
as many things he's been the best super
smash bros melee player in the world one
of the five gods of smash a frame data
pioneer the only player to be ranked
number one in both melee and its sequel
Super Smash Bros Brawl at the same time
right when I start turns people put me
top 25 in the world like pretty fast
like top 25 where I was a rat right
ranked 15
pretty quickly and then we can't write
one about a year and half later but
above all else
mew2king is proof that if you work hard
enough you can be the best - King was
born on February 5th 1989 in cinnaminson
New Jersey and became obsessed with
video games at a young age on his old
web sites he listed endless records he
had in games like f-zero GX Mario Kart
Double Dash and of course super smash
bros melee but when m2k started playing
competitively he failed to make a mark
simply put he just wasn't that good and
he wasn't a natural by any means but he
had a work ethic at the time that was
unmatched and for most players feels
unmatched you can only get so good off
never playing a human that knows
anything about the game like of course
their first time it's gonna be like oh
well you have a lot to learn that's
natural there isn't much footage of that
time in Mewtwo King's life because no
one cared about a player who couldn't
succeed he decided to do his homework
and study you - King spent hours upon
hours amassing information about the
game
if he wasn't good at the game he needed
to know everything about it
frame data percentages recovery time get
up attack let's grab some stats
everything m2k pioneer data on melee he
knew things no one else would four years
and he shared it online of the key alone
I was just like kind of a kid who's just
curious about everything and it's like
Who am I wonder how fast this movie I
wonder how far this kid he's a curious
and just being curious makes you just
want to know things by year 2005 he
started entering real tournaments and
started climbing fast
he went from twenty third to ninth to
third at MLG New York m2k placed 7th at
MLG Dallas he fell to eighth but he kept
pushing third in Chicago fourth in Las
Vegas second in Long Island first at Evo
East and first at Evo West
he wasn't just good he was constantly
getting better by 2007 he went from
being an unknown scrub to a contender
for the best in the world he was caught
in a 3-way race with Daniel Korean DJ
Jung and Christopher PC Chris Seagal for
the title of best in the world but their
struggle was put aside momentarily with
the release of Super Smash Bros Brawl
brawl was a slower less complicated game
and one that most melee players didn't
like but m2k saw brawl as different not
necessarily worse and started grinding
once again obviously and then drunk him
out oh wait I was like what's driving
the best of that like oh that's that
mew2king was the top ranked melee and
brawl player in the world from 2008 to
2009 the melee scene was stagnating but
m2k was still one of the best and he
proved it at revival of melee MLG had
pulled
of smash in 2007 so the community
returned to their grassroots nature and
put on the biggest melee tournament
since the release of brawl
I told Alucard from New York or
something's like okay if you host a ROM
in it and you invite mango then I'll go
then I'll go and I'll have motivation to
actually care because right now is just
like just beat everyone for free except
mango and that's actually funny because
that's actually what happened because I
beat up on for free except mango
[Music]
Richard
[Music]
back hair like 150 she's supposed to die
early
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mentally starving
[Music]
it's dirty because there's no risk
involved
[Music]
yes
mango choking back a smile he's biting
his lip that's why I'm mecha you can
smile m2k worked his way through the
bracket until he faced branson dishes
whiz Layton in the losers finals
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
despite his incredible play mewtwoking
started building up bad press the once
revered player became a controversial
figure after several bracket
manipulation incidents came to light as
a result m2k was banned from the 2010
MLG finals after he took $500 from Wyatt
ADHD Beekman who beat him and the losers
finals in May 2011 mew2king ADHD and
Jason aunty Bates were given yellow
cards for splitting their prize money
following Mewtwo Kings fourth place
forfeit later that year at Genesis 2
mew2king was given a red card for
allegedly sandbagging in pools m2k
defended himself by saying he wasn't in
a good mood during the sets and claiming
pot splitting was common practice back
then but the damage was done
Mewtwo Kings image was shot and smashers
were spreading rumors and exaggerating
tales of mew2king being awkward or
otherwise embarrassing after late 2010
it was like a three year time period
where is this like kind of
soul-searching life I just didn't really
have motivation for whatever while m2k
became a growing meme within the
community and the only way to silence
the haters was to conquer them hi guys
I'll see you later
in late 2013
mew2king won 17 straight melee
tournaments after not having taken a
major in nearly a year his slump didn't
matter the controversies vanished but
since then mew2king has struggled the
release of Super Smash Bros 4 Wii U
effectively killed brawl and while m2k
was extremely strong in Smash 4 at the
start he could not keep it up he leaned
back on melee where he has continued to
consistently place in the top eight but
he isn't dominating any
oh wait went back and battles news and
mango
it's just smash con 2017
he might not finish in first place every
time
but he's always a contender Oh gets
another grab Oh will we see a pop-up no
we won't
[Applause]
no it's can't simply put you can never
count out me to Kane he's taken first
place at at least one Meili tournament
every single year since 2006 and he
didn't do it through raw skill or having
the best practice partners he did it by
doing his homework studying more and
working harder than almost any Smasher
in the business he is proof that anyone
can win anyone can be the best anyone
can stay the best that the king can
always return mew2king is more than a
god
mew2king is an institution thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button
[Music]